- Welcome everyone.
This is our second seminar
from the Refugee Program,
for the fall 2021.
Today we have the pleasure
of having Dr. Dany Bahar.
He's an associate professor
at Brown University,
Watson Institute for
International and Public Affairs,
and a non-resident senior fellow
at the Brooking Institution Global Economy
and Development Program.
He is an Israelian-Venezuelan economist,
with affiliation to the Growth Lab
at Harvard Center for
International Development,
CESifo Group Munich,
and IZA Institute of Labor Economics.
Dr. Bahar research sits
at the intersection
of international economics
and economic development.
In particular, he focuses on
the diffusion of technology
and knowledge within and across borders,
as well as topics related
to structural transformation
and productivity dynamics.
Lately, his focus has been
towards migrants and refugees
as an asset in the process
of economic development.
Today, he will be speaking about
the Global Mobile Inventor.
So Dany, the floor is yours.
- Thank you, Teresa.
And thanks everybody for
coming or joining on Zoom.
It's great to be here.
I just moved to New England,
and one of the parents,
they told me, "You're close to Yale,
and all those universities."
And now when I get the
chance to go to Yale,
I'm going on Zoom, but next time.
And thank you for the invitation.
It's great to be here with you guys.
So I know that this is
a series about refugees
and I am doing some work on refugees,
but this one in particular,
I'm barely, I'm not gonna
talk about refugees.
So, so it's going to be a little bit,
hopefully it stands out.
And, but of course in the Q & A, you know,
we can talk more about
other stuff we're doing
on the refugee aspect of it,
but this is kind of, a
bit of a different crowd.
And it's I think,
a very exciting project that we started,
we just started.
And when I mean,
we just started this just
two years ago before COVID
and this is joined with Raj Choudhury
from Harvard Business School
and Ernest Miguelez
from the Université de Bordeaux,
who I think he's in the crowd.
So, if there are questions on the chat,
I think Ernest will be,
he probably has answers that I don't.
So he will be, also jump in.
Anyway, let me start a little
bit with some, I guess, some
some motivation.
And this quote we found
from I think a philosopher, Carlo Cipolla,
who said, "Through the
ages, the main channel
for the diffusion of innovation
has been the migration
of people."
And of course here,
one of the,
one of the most notable
examples is this generation
of migrant scientists
who arrived to the US.
And you could very much say,
you know, in a refugee status,
the refugee status (indistinct)
really before World War 2.
And, eh, you know, it's
attributed that these scientists
in their many different
fields really shaped
or lead shaped all science spectrum
in the US and in the world.
And, you know, one,
and there has been research done on this.
I'm going to mention it,
but the research by
Pedro Moser stands out.
And, you know,
it's clear that despite
the horrible circumstances
for which these scientists had to come,
had to flee their countries,
the success of the US in this case,
in everything that has to do
with science and innovation
in the big part is due to this transfer
of brains and of people who settled here.
And I think this paper goes a little bit
to speak about this.
Let me start with one
example of what is it
that we're after, an
anecdote I'll example.
Meet Ismael Mena.
Ismael Mena, he is, what I
think is a pioneer inventor,
he patented the first
ever patent in Chile,
in the technology class A61B,
which is a CPC
classification in the USPTO,
the US Patents and Trade Office.
So the first ever patent
that happened out of Chile
in that classification was made
by this gentleman called Ismael Mena.
And this,
the subclass A61B,
of course we don't know
exactly what it means,
but it's everything that has
to do with instruments in terms
of diagnostics and surgical and,
and medical instruments basically.
After Israel Mena patented,
Ismael Mena, sorry,
patented this first patent
in Chile ever in 1996,
there were 17 more patents in that class,
nine inventors in Chile,
and by the,
these are 17 patents by 19
other inventors in Chile
that happened after this first patent.
So, you know, one question
I had, it's like, how come,
how did this guy do it?
Now, how did you get to a country?
Or like, you are,
you're an inventor and you
start patenting something
that nobody else in the
country has done before,
you know, it takes some I don't
know, courage, creativity,
how did you guys do it?
So I went and looked,
I mean this is a cherry picked example,
of course, but I went and
I looked into this patent.
So this is the patent
that Ismael Mena filed
in 1996.
It was filed in 1996.
It was transferred in 1998
We can talk about, we're
gonna talk about that later,
but you'll see, it's a
patent with a lot of people,
some of them in the US.
But Ismael Mena is in
Chile, in Santiago, Chile.
So of course you could
say, well, you know,
he was patenting with other
people that knew about this
and all that, and that's all fair, but,
but stick with me for a
minute for the motivation
for this story.
But what's interesting here
is that when I go and I search
more of this person, Ismael Mena,
I find that another patent
in 1994, 2 years before,
in the same subclass.
So exactly in the same technologies,
where Ismael Mena in Los Angeles, right.
So, it turns out he was in the US,
where maybe he did his
degree, where he was working.
He patented, he learned
about this technology,
and then he moved to Chile,
which presumably is his home country.
And then he patented more
in that same technology.
So
our answer,
and this is what I'm going to
try to show you some evidence
in this talk or answers, how did he do it?
How did Ismael Mena was the first person
to ever patent a new technology for Chile,
is because he was at
Global Mobile Inventor.
- Dany, can I ask a question
for clarification here?
So the story,
I mean, one way to interpret
your story is that,
the inventor, wherever he goes,
he invents and he takes
invention to a new place, right?
Another way to interpret
the story is that you move
to a new institutional
environment where you might,
you might not have necessarily a new idea,
but in that environment,
those regulations,
you might want patent the same invention
or the same idea that you had, right,
that there's some value
to patenting in the US,
there's some separate value
to patenting in Chile as well.
And which, which interpretation is,
is the one you would like us to.
- I, if I understood it, right,
I think it's more of a first one.
Are you, by the second
one, are you saying?
- The second one is like,
there's not necessarily a new innovation
that's moving to a new place,
same innovation, given a
new regulatory environment,
I might want to patent again.
- I see. No, I think
it's more the first one,
because these are all patent in the USPTO,
in the same office, if
that answers your question.
- [Ahmed] Oh, okay, okay.
So it's not that he's
just replicating something
in another country, but from Chile,
he's now doing an additional patent
in the same patent office.
So it's something above and beyond.
- I see, so when we move
to the quantitative aspect
of your work,
it will be holding constant,
the institutional environment,
like in terms of, like
say, the patent, okay.
- Absolutely, yes, yes, exactly.
Yes.
That's a good, that's a great point.
Okay, so, I mean,
I'm making here a big
claim and I'm going to try
to show evidence, and to
see how far we can get.
So, so what do we do in
this paper in particular?
So we really throw this idea
of what we call Global
Mobile Inventors or GMIs.
And we're going to try to
answer questions such as,
how common are these GMIs,
and how do they differ from
other types of inventors?
Are they really,
do they really have very
different characteristics?
Can GMI's explain the emergence
of new technology classes
in the countries they go to?
And these are some, yes, exactly.
Keeping constant as much
as we can including the
institutional environment.
What else can we learn
about GMI's being pioneers
and in the process of diffusion
of knowledge and technology?
And here, I must be, I'm going
to be honest and upfront,
and please keep bringing
up these questions.
You know, in this work in progress,
we don't have yet a fancy
identification strategy.
I'm not sure we really need it because we,
because in essence,
I think a lot of what we're trying
to do is really descriptive
to try to show the evidence.
So what, who are these people?
And I think we have some pretty
strong and robust patents
that makes it interesting.
However, you know, I'm
going to talk about that,
we are still trying to see if there's room
for improvement when it
comes to identification
and you know, of course we
welcome ideas on that front.
- [Sanjeev] I have a question.
- [Dany] Yes.
- [Sanjeev] So, does it
matter if the movement
of the GMI's are volitional
or non volitional.
- [Dany] Are voluntary?
- [Sanjeev] Volitional, like, you know,
if they intend to move or
they were forced to move.
- [Dany] I mean, it matters
in terms of endogeneity
of self selection, right-
- [Sanjeev] Yeah.
- [Dany] You're going to.
- [Dany] Of course, it doesn't matter
and I think that's going to
be our biggest challenge,
but here, you know, without
getting too much ahead of time,
there are kind of two
views of the world here.
I mean, one of them,
let's imagine a firm wants to start being
in something, you know, that
they don't have the local,
the local know power, the local skills to,
and they will actually bring
somebody from the same firm,
from another location
and from another firm.
That is a self-selection
process happening in process.
The question is whether,
you know, that still means
that the counterfactual
of that firm wouldn't be
able to continue patent
without that person.
So, you know, we don't
want to make a strong claim
about that, but I am putting up front here
that the fact that, you know,
we're not coming here with saying, like,
here's a perfect identification.
There could be important selections.
We try to show, you know, we
try to watch clean as we can,
but your point is great.
And, and yes, I mean,
most of these moves are
going to be voluntarily.
- [Sanjeev] Thank you.
- [Dany] I hope though
that you still find cool and interesting,
what we going to find,
even though we do have
room for improvement
in terms of identification strategy.
- [Sanjeev] So at the
macro level, it's like,
the evidence is quite clear
that like the movement
of European Jews to let's say America led
to lot of innovations,
you know.-
- [Dany] Right.
- [Sanjeev] But at the individual level,
I have not seen the evidence.
So, I mean, I'm very curious, thank you.
- [Dany] Yeah, so, I think this
is an attempt of doing that.
You know, I think that
the work by Pedro Moser
and the work, I,
I have special mention
to them by Shai Bernstein
from Stanford and co-workers,
show a little bit of
that on that direction,
but not so much on the
emergence of new technology.
They measure the knowledge
diffusion through other books,
and I think we're going into
that direction of success.
All right, so, so some
of the main findings
we put out there.
So, so first of all,
we do find that these GMIs are superstars.
And I'm gonna specify this very clearly,
if they have longer careers,
they patent much more,
they patent higher quality innovations,
but there's of course
something special about them.
What I think is our main
and most important result is this one.
And it's that GMIs are
significantly more present
in the first stages of the development
of a new technology class in
their countries of destination.
And I'm going to show you a
little bit of evidence of this.
And it goes back a
little bit to the example
of the beginning of Ismael Mena.
We also find that this
prevalence disappears over time.
So like, as the life cycle
of a technology advances,
we see less presence of GMIs,
which dwarfs, could be
interpreted as a sign that once,
once that knowledge has been transferred,
as more and more patents
are being invented
in that technology,
the knowledge becomes embedded
in the local inventors.
And once I get to their craft,
I'm gonna be more specific
about what I'm saying.
We don't find strong evidence
though, that the quality
of the patenting significantly
changes when there,
when there are GMIs involved
in the first few patents
of that technology in a given country.
So we do find that the
technologies start off
with a higher presence of GMIs,
but when it comes to quality,
you know, as much as we can
measure the counterfactual,
we don't see it as much.
All right.
So it's very hard to do justice
to a very long literature,
but a little bit of what we
think is our main conclusion.
First of all, on the eulogy literature,
on the Globalization of Innovation.
You know, there's a lot of papers showing
that innovation is becoming
more globally traded,
there's many more patents that
are global collaborations,
there's a lot of cross cited,
cross country citations.
And also there's a lot of recent evidence,
but very growing and
very (indistinct) that,
that a lot of the innovation is happening,
thanks to immigration flows.
And, you know, we have here a long list.
And I think here
that our particular
contribution contributions,
that we come and provide
evidence of a new aspect
of globalization, and go very deep
into this phenomenon called the GMIs,
which is like really starting the people,
these innovators that are
moving across borders,
and how are they shaping innovation
in the country say they arrived to.
Much beyond citations, a
lot of the focus on this,
on this literature has been on citations,
how knowledge transfer through citation,
who are actually looking more
at the emergence of new technologies.
And of course in that sense,
there's a long literature on,
on human mobility and the
diffusion of knowledge.
And, you know, Sanjeev also mentioned
that there's good,
that it has been very well established,
more than macro level
that there are scientists,
you know, migrants
if you know how in technologies,
and there's a long list.
And as I said before,
I think there's a special mention
to the world, like Pedro
Moser and co-workers
and Shai Bernstein and co -workers,
who really look at the
evidence at more macro level
of scientists, importing knowledge.
Shai Bernstein and co-workers
do it more with citations.
And Pedro and co-workers
do it more with scientists
that goes to inventors and patents.
If, you know,
in a few words, I think we
are really bringing some,
you know, the universe of
patent using macro data
to measure the emergence
of new technologies through diffusion.
And this builds a little bit
on a previous work of ours
with Raj Choudhury and Hillel Rapoport.
We do this a little bit at a macro level.
Okay, so are, the data
we're going to use is,
our main data source is PatentsView.
PatentsView is a website or
a data visualization tool
that is maintained by the
office of the chief economies
of the USPTO and partners
that includes several
organizations and universities.
The University of
Amherst is involved here.
And I'm going to tell you
what makes this very special,
if you, if you don't know about it,
the platform contains the
universe of patents granted
by the USPTO from 1976 to present.
That doesn't mean, I mean, we,
these are granted from 1976,
so you might see patent that
have been applied to before
in 1976.
So in essence,
what makes this data set special is
that they use some complex algorithms,
some machine learning to
disambiguate the names
of the inventors and of assignees,
which are the firms that
the patents are assigned to,
where they most of the
time, when an inventor,
if an inventor is working with IBM,
the inventor is listed on the patent,
but the assignee is going
to be IBM, for instance.
So, we have a unique identifier for both.
So basically we can really track inventors
across time and space.
So each time an inventor
will patent an invention,
that inventor will list his or her address
at the time of filing.
And of course the assignees.
So we can really see all
the movement of people
as long as they're patenting,
which is important, right?
So as long as we see patenting activity,
we can really see mobility
of people across borders.
I mean, we can do it across
cities if we want it to,
in this paper, we're
focusing just across borders.
And of course we can identify assignees,
which is, and firms, which is important
because we don't do a whole
lot of that right now,
but we are also looking
a little bit about,
and maybe Sanjeev, this goes
a little bit to your question.
Not exactly, but we are
looking a little bit
into movements within
the firm or across firms.
And, you know, we see some
heterogeneity there, and,
but of course we have
much more information
to work here, if you want it to.
So our sample, you know,
we actually going to limit our patents to
that have an application
date between 1970 and 2015.
So, as I said before,
the patents are granted starting in 76,
but I could have filed a patent the 1970,
that was granted in 76 or vice versa.
There's a patent that was granted in 76,
but it could have been applied, you know,
I could have filed it 10
years ago, 10 years before,
or 5 years before.
So we have all these, we stop into 2015,
just because some, often we use
like citations measures and,
and to avoid like results being biased
by right-tail censoring.
We just strive to call it a
little bit, because you do see,
like, towards the end of the sample,
you see a lot of right-tail
censoring of many measures,
but none of this is really
changing our results.
So we, when it comes to when
an invention is happening,
we're going to use the application date
or priority date if earlier.
So again, the application days when I go
to the patent office and say,
I want to apply with this
patent, like when we, you know,
the submission date of the journal, right,
which is different than
the publication date.
There are certain patents when I,
again we're using here only the USPTO.
So the US Patent and Trademark Office,
so we're using only one office.
And of course they are inventors
everywhere in the world
that can patent in, through the US office.
Sometimes these inventors also patent
in the European Patent Office.
Or they also patent in the
Japanese Patent Office.
And when this happens, if you patented,
let's say you patent it first
in the European Patent office,
and then you patent the
same, the same invention
in the USPTO, so to
have more jurisdictions,
we're actually going to use the date
of the first patent that
you filed in this case,
the European Patent office, right.
So if we have a priority
date that is earlier,
we're gonna use that.
And this is pretty
standard in the literature.
We just do it because
that's the time where,
that most closely resembles
when the innovation actually happens,
I suppose, to the granting date.
This is just like admin, right,
I'm going through it, with you.
So our sample includes about
6 million granted patents,
and they belong to about
15 million inventors.
And each patent is classified
to a technology subclass,
according to the CPC codes,
which is the one that USPTO uses,
which is the Comparative
Patent Classification.
Theses are like four digits
or four character patent classes,
and there are about 623 of them.
So every time I'm talking
about technology class
or a technology subclass,
sometimes I mix the two,
but I'm referring to this,
I'm referring to the four digit CPC codes.
And, you know, we're gonna,
we are going to compliment...
Oops.
Yeah, we just, we're going
to talk about this later,
we compliment this with some
quality level measures from,
from our ECB data set by
Squicciarini, Dernis and Criscuolo.
Okay, let me start showing you some data.
Interrupt me, if there are any questions.
So, so these, for instance,
just simply like how many
patents are filed per year
in our sample from 1970 to 2015.
Of course at the beginning,
there are very, very few, because again,
because PatentsView starts only
with patents granted in 1976.
There's very few patents
that were filed in 1970
and waited six years to be granted.
So of course in the beginning,
there's very little.
But overall this reflects, I mean,
I think what we should
take from this graphic,
it reflects that, you know,
during the nineties as expected,
there was a huge boom in innovation,
in patents filed all over the world.
So, this is kind of
what we're working with.
Okay.
This is a very cool graph.
It's not exactly what our sample is,
but it's what I thought
it was so cool to show.
And it's basically,
where are the inventors?
And this takes the USPTO,
it takes inventors from other offices.
And basically, you know, we
geo located, we geo-coded data,
you see where actually the
inventors were located.
And I mean, no surprise.
Most of them, of course, are
in the US, Europe and in Asia
and East Asia.
And, you know, very little
across the developing countries,
as we know, most innovation,
most formally innovation
happens in these countries.
Oh, this is not showing,
there's some, there's, anyway.
Okay, so the, I'm sorry
that the legend here,
is not complete.
So basically this is another graph,
showing a little bit what,
which one are the, you know,
where in which countries are the inventors
that are filing the most in
terms of countries as a whole.
And this is basically
showing you, you know,
the US is this purple line.
It doesn't show in the legend,
but the US of course is the
number one filer of patents
or inventors in the US are
the number one inventors,
filers of patents.
Then you have Japan, if I'm not mistaken.
Then you have Germany.
China is this green line,
like you see how it's rising very rapidly
in the past two decades.
Anyway, just some descriptive
statistics for you to see.
But just to show you kind
of a little bit the extent
to which we have data.
- [Sanjeev] Dany, Can I
please ask a simple question?
- Yes, please.
- [Sanjeev] Can you trace
these inventors to organization
that they were part of?
- Yes.
- [Sanjeev] Okay.
Like, do you have any
sense, like maybe in Japan,
like, you know, maybe in
Japan, like, you know,
it's a more self-employed
inventors who are active
or in America, it's
more organization based?
Do you have any sense about...
- I don't have a sense right now
but that's very easy to find out.
I mean, I can follow up assigned.
Am I sensing that most of them,
I think that they're very,
I don't know how to send this across,
I mean, if we can write into the chat,
but, you know, it's better to read out,
but I think that most
of these patents are,
you mostly always have an
organization behind you.
It could be a university too,
but I know that multinationals,
I count for like, I don't know, 80%,
but a, you know, a big chunk
of the patents that are filed,
I think most of them actually
do belong to an organization.
- [Sanjeev] Oh, okay, okay
- But I can, that's easy,
that's really easy to look in this data.
- [Sanjeev] Okay.
Thanks.
Alright.
So let's go to the meat here.
So who is a Global Mobile Inventor?
How do we define him or her?
And we are here have to make a little bit
of some arbitrary decision.
So, so basically, you know,
the short answer is like anybody,
any inventor who patents
more than one country
throughout his or her
career and hasn't moved
across borders, we classify
that person as a GMI.
This doesn't mean this
person is a migrant,
we are aware that we can with this data,
classify somebody as a migrant or not,
because we don't know the
country that they were born in.
There were some database, databases
on the European Patent office
that had your nationality.
We don't have that here.
So we're not making a big
claim about migration,
but, you know,
it's fair to think that a lot
of these people are actually migrants.
I have a question.
- [AJ] Hi, Dany.
- Hi there.
- [AJ] This is AJ.
I have a quick question.
So, by the way that you're defining a GMI,
this to me sounds like by definition,
you're excluding people
who would, for instance,
come to the US, studied in the
US, get their PhD, whatever,
and not have time to let's say,
apply for a patent and then start working
in a place like Google,
and then actually be incentivized to,
to apply for a patent there.
Yeah, so you're essentially missing out
on a group of younger generation who gets
into that stage of applying
for patents a little bit differently.
So could you speak to
that a little bit more?
And what do you think this type
of exclusion does to your results?
- Yeah, I know that's a good point.
And we are, I mean, I think
you're starting, if somebody,
like I'm an immigrant in the US
and let's say my first patent
is in the US and, you know,
I don't move anywhere else.
I wouldn't be a GMI in this dataset.
We do have, and I'm going to get to that,
some name analysis
where we kind of try to,
based on your location and your
name, try to say something,
whether you are an
immigrant or a returnee,
and we do some work with that,
but I don't have a great answer for it.
I mean, it's a great point.
And I take it and you're right.
You're absolutely right.
We're not, I mean, for you to be, I mean,
let me even go one more step
there, for you to be a GMI,
you need to have at least two patents.
Right.
You can.
- [AJ] Precisely, both
in your home country
or wherever you start from another place.
And if he, if you follow this logic
that you just opened up as well,
if you're coming from a country
that has heavy regulations
on patents, applying for a
patent, then by definition,
you're excluding very low-income settings.
- Absolutely.
No, I agree, I mean, that
I guess that the, you know,
the boring answer to your
very good question is like,
that's why we're not, we're
not using the term migrant.
It goes very far.
We're using Mobile Inventors
as people who actually do invent,
we know they're inventors and move around.
It's hard for me to say how that will kind
of bias where we're doing.
And I mean, if anything,
I guess it could well
underestimate what we're doing.
- [AJ] I think you may
be overestimating how,
creme de la creme these people are,
because you're essentially
removing the people who are early
on in their careers.
So you're really comparing
people who have had the chance
to both apply for a patent in
their domestic or wherever,
and then somewhere else.
So you really looking at
people who are top achievers.
- Yeah, so when I'm going to,
I'm going to show you the first comparison
in a couple of slides
and we do, I mean we do,
I mean, this is not perfect but it kind
of goes a bit to your point.
It's like we compare
them to other inventors
that also have two patents.
Just to make a little bit
more apples and apples,
but you're right,
I'm not evading your point,
it sees a limitation
where we're, you know,
and we have to keep, I
mean, we're open about it
and we're, we're not
going to claim otherwise.
You're absolutely right.
- Thank you for responding so kindly.
- Yeah, of course.
Okay, so, you know, then,
so bear with me that we're going
with this definition based on the data,
and then a question arise, which is like,
okay, you are a GMI, but
for how long are you a GMI?
Are you a GMI for, you know,
the first hour since you moved?
And I mean, so for the first
patent, are you a GMI forever?
Are you a GMI for six months?
For two years?
We have to define some framework to do it.
And here I'm actually going
to show you how we do that
with a cartoon.
There you are.
There's some of the gray, but anyway,
so let's say we see this inventor.
She has a patent in country A right,
and we're going to have three,
we're going to be using
three definitions of GMIs.
In year one, this person patented,
so we see her in our data.
Then we see her again on
year three on country B.
So, so she, you know, we
assume, and the thing is,
it's a fair assumption
that she should have moved
in between year one and year three.
And, you know, just to keep it simple,
we're just doing this example,
where this person actually
stays in country B,
we can have people moving around
and I can answer questions
about that, but let's
keep it simple for now.
So we have three definitions.
The first one let's say is a
GMI just for the first patent.
So we count you only as a GMI
when you do your first patent
in another country.
And if you, if I see you
patenting again in the future,
you're not a GMI anymore in our sample,
that's definition number one.
Then we have, what I think
is kind of the mothering one,
which is GMI for one year, which is like,
we can't use the GMI after you move
and every time you patent
within the first year, you are,
you're still at GMI, right.
You're still like, you know, just came,
you might be in the process
of bringing the know-how,
et cetera, et cetera.
And then we have kind of the most extreme,
I don't know if extreme, but the most,
the largest definition is like,
well, you have a GMI always,
which is, you know,
it doesn't matter what happened
as long as you move once,
you're always a GMI.
We have to set some structure
and this is the way we went through it.
For most of the results,
I'm going to tell you today,
we are, I'm going to show you results
with the one year GMI definition.
You know, everything
is really robust with,
with all of them, but, you know,
we just have to stick to one for,
I don't want to show you
three tables every time
for everything, but we're
using this definition
and just to set the stage.
Okay.
So let me show you a little bit more data.
So...
Tell me if that wasn't clear,
this is important, right.
If, I guess if there are
any questions, just jump in.
Okay, so these just a
snapshot basically of the,
of the top 50 corridors
between 2015 and 2019.
So basically, what this
graph is doing is showing all
of the movements that have
been between 2015 and 2019
in the top 50 countries
that have movements.
This actually should be,
these are not 50 countries,
these are I think 20.
So that's, that's a typo error.
I'm sorry.
So, I mean, basically what
this graph is telling you,
this is the US,
this blue, you know, this
blue part here is the US
and these blue lines are all
inventors leaving the US,
moving out of the US.
You see a lot of them are going to China.
A lot of them are going to Canada.
A lot of them are going to
Japan, et cetera, et cetera.
It sounds like ret, you know,
you could, you could think
and we do find evidence of that,
that these are kind of
returnees or returning.
China is a big country of origin,
of managing GMI's, a lot
of them going to the US
but also to Taiwan,
interestingly, and, and a lot.
Okay, so this is kind of a glimpse
of the richness of the data we have.
I have a lot of descriptive graphs.
So I'm going to, for the sake of time,
I might need to skip some,
but this is also like how many
movements are year to year
in our data set.
So you see, you know, in the latest years,
first of all, you'll see that
this is a growing phenomenon.
I mean, in the 1990s,
as compared to today,
I mean, these, the numbers
of international movements
of inventors have quadrupled.
So, so it's a really rising phenomenon,
which we think is really important.
And, you know,
as more the share of all these movements,
are people moving within the firm,
but actually most of them
are moving across firms.
This is something we can
do, Sanjeev with your,
with what you were referring
to before then the fact
that we can really track assignees
to other firms with a unique identifier.
This is interesting, I
wasn't really expecting
that most of them will be across firms.
This is too of much information here.
So, but, but just I'll
walk you very quickly.
I mean, these are the main corridors
of movements, you know,
per five-year periods.
So,
you know, you start seeing
that the first corridor
in the eighties and the nineties was
from Great Britain to the USA,
and then it changed from USA to China,
which is really interesting.
And you start seeing
really a lot of changes
in the past 20 years of
how things are moving.
And...
So, now let me go to the,
this does not make justice
to AJ's previous comments,
but I think it's kind of
a step in that direction.
So, so again,
we're not able to explicitly
find a GMI as an immigrant,
but we do perform a name
analysis for those purposes.
And I think you probably have
seen many papers doing this.
We're not doing anything very new.
So I'm kind of going to go
a little bit fast over this,
unless there's questions,
but basically, you know,
with certain algorithms,
basically we're relying
on the IBM Global Name Recognition system,
which is based...
And Ernest is here.
Ernest, who was my co-author
he's here, and he did this.
So he might correct me.
This is based mostly on names
of people who are coming,
immigrating to the US.
So this is mostly for outside of US names.
So using this data set,
we can actually track
and give a probability essentially
of the country your from,
both from your first
name and your last name.
So, you know, we take the
names from PatentsView,
this name, for instance, Laroia, Rajiv.
We know that the surname, you know,
has 99% likelihood of being from India.
1% like of being from France.
And the first name, 81%
likelihood of being from India
and these are the other countries.
So based on this,
we actually define based on
your last name, what is your,
the country of your ethnicity, if you may.
Using this, we kind of, we
mark, we do our best to,
this is not a great, this
is not a perfect algorithm,
but we do our best to mark you,
if you're a GMI as an
immigrant or as a returnee.
So what does that mean
Wei Rao, for instance,
who's in our data set,
and he has, for instance,
three patents as you see here on the left,
is the same inventor,
has the same inventor id,
and he patents the first
two patents in China
and then moves to the US.
So he's a GMI.
And he, we mark him as
an immigrant in the US
and not a returnee, right.
Because his last name and
his name resembles names
in China.
This is kinds of the easy case.
Also we have, if the GMI is
coming in the host country,
we mark that person as a returnee, right.
So, Marco Panneilo,
patented in Great Britain,
and then we see Marco patented from Italy.
And this name resembles
an Italian last name.
So we count that person has a returnee.
Then we get into more complicated things
that I'm going to skip, because
then whatever you do, if,
you know for, anyway,
I'm going to skip this part
because it gets a little bit complicated,
but I'm happy to talk
about it up, I'm fine.
There's some, there's a bunch of cases
and we try to make justice.
But in, you know, in the
big scheme of things,
the point here is we do
our best, we try to define
if a person is an immigrant or
returnee based on the names.
When we do that,
and here, I'm showing you again,
these corridors, you know,
things kind of change a little bit.
So you see that when
it comes to immigrants,
we see that, you know,
traditionally that the
most common corridor was
from Japan to the US.
Then in the mid 2006, it
becomes from China to the US.
You know, you start
seeing like most, a lot,
you start seeing the US
as a recipient country much more often.
And when you look at returnees,
you kind of, the picture turns around.
So you start seeing the US
as the sending country much more often,
and the receiving countries,
you see China and Korea
and, you know, Germany, India,
you start seeing India in this top 10.
So, so you start seeing also
some developing countries.
Alright, so, so this to me,
I think it's a very important graph.
And here, if I haven't
convinced you already,
how important this phenomenon
is, I think that this graph,
at least to me, it's convincing.
There, and...
Here, basically we're
comparing how frequent,
how many patents or
what's the share of patent
that have GMI's across time.
And here we're measuring GMIs
with the three different definitions.
Of course, when we,
when we use the most generous
definition of always,
you know, the share of
patents is very, very high
because it accumulates people,
but, and here we're,
but we're basically comparing the share
of patents of people who are GMIs
to the share of patents that are GCPS,
which are Global Collaborative Patents.
There's a very important influential paper
by Will Kerr and Sari Kerr
showing this important phenomenon
of these global collaborative patents,
patents that are filed by inventors living
in two different countries
or two or more different countries,
you know, they claim
it's a big phenomenon.
It's a great paper.
You know, you can learn a lot there
about these globalization of innovation.
And here, I think we're showing
that when we look at GMIs,
it's a very comparable
phenomenon when it comes
to its size and velocity.
So, I think that this was an
important graph for us to,
you know, a little bit, to
compare apples to apples.
Okay.
This is going slower than what I thought.
So, when I, I do wanna
try to get to the results,
but this here is kind of what
I'm trying to show, you know,
who are these people really?
And how do they differ?
So for a bunch of different measures here,
I'm not going to go through all of them,
but like how many patents you
filed throughout your life,
in how many countries you
filed throughout your life?
How many firms did you work with?
Or like, how many
assignees are your patents?
What share of your patents are patented
for the top 100 assignees,
for the firms that patent the most,
how many active years you
have since your first patent,
or your most recent patent?
And then a bunch of things
including some quality measures
and so on.
This is the mean for GMIs, this
number for the average GMI.
So the average GMI patent,
17 patents throughout
his, or her lifetime.
It patents in two plus countries
throughout his or her lifetime.
It patents for almost
for four different firms.
Half of their patents or almost
half of their patents are
in the top hundred assignees.
They're active for almost 15 years, right.
And then you have a
bunch of other measures
and you know, their quality,
it's also quite high as
compared to the two followings
that I'm going to tell you.
So, the first two columns
here is like comparing
to the average non-GMI.
So everybody who's an
inventor who doesn't move,
of course here, you know, the
country, if you're a non GMI,
but if initially you only
have one country, right.
And here to make a little bit of justice
towards AJ was saying before,
which is a great point.
We are comparing it also
to people who patent two patents or more
because maybe the superstars doesn't come
from the fact that you moving,
the superstars come from the fact
that you patented more than once.
And even there yet, we do
see important differences.
So these deltas here are the
differences between these GMIs
and these non GMIS, and,
you know, across the board,
these GMIs are really superstars,
patenting higher quality,
patenting for a longer
time, making more patents,
you know, working for bigger
firms, et cetera, et cetera.
So,
all right.
Let me go a little bit more
into the, into the more,
a little bit more rigorous, empirical work
that we're doing.
So, one of the main questions
that is driving us is like,
you know, what is, what
role GMI's play in the,
in the life cycle of a
country and a technology?
So what we do for this
is that we basically sort
for each country and
each technology class.
So think about, you know,
each country and each
four digit technology,
we sort chronologically all
the patents within that cell.
Right, from the first ever patent ever in,
for that country in that
cell, for instance, in Chile,
in medical instruments,
the first one would be
the patent by Ismael Mena,
we saw at the beginning.
And then we sort them chronologically
until the most recent
patent we have in the data.
And then we just simply
divide it in 10 chunks,
like 10 deciles, the
first 10%, the second 10%,
the third 10% and so on.
So we estimate, we want
to try to get a sense
of how frequent or how
likely it is to see a GMI
in each one of these deciles.
The first decile ever, the
second decile and so on.
But we wanna, I mean,
we have enough power to add some controls,
but we don't want to do
just a simple average.
So, basically what we
do is that on the left,
we run our aggression,
on the left, we have like a binary power,
whether it's, whether
you are a GMI or not.
Here, we have a set of dummies
per country and technology
for the 10 deciles.
Okay.
And then we add some
country year fixed effects,
some technology year fixed effects.
And, you know, we do a lot
more robustness status,
but this is what we find.
And I think this graph to
us is kind of a it's...
I don't know about you,
but I really like it.
So this is what this graph is showing us.
This graph is showing the
probability of seeing a GMI
for a given, for the average
country and technology
in each one of the
deciles of the lifecycle
of that technology in that country.
So what you're seeing
everything is relative
to the most recent 10, to
the most recent deciles.
So the latest 10% of patent.
Of course, here we have, you know,
we only keep countries and technologies
that have at least 10 patents.
So what we find here is that,
in the first 10% of patents ever,
in a given country or a
technology, you have a,
like a little bit more than
half a percentage point higher
in the likelihood of seeing a GMI than
in the most recent decile.
You still see that in the second decile,
you still see it in the third decile.
It starts this,
the significance of the
estimates starts disappearing
after the fourth, the fourth decile.
So after 40% or after, you know, a few,
a few patents in the country,
it seems like GMIs are not
present anymore in the life cycle
of these patent, which
could be interpreted,
and that's our interpretation that
as time goes by, the
ability to keep innovating
in that same technology is fully embedded
in local inventors.
Not in, not in global GMIs.
- Dany, here,
could it be just the same inventors
that say filed the first patent,
but because of your definition of GMI,
they just stopped being considered GMIs.
Or is that?
- So we try these with all
these three definitions
and its robust.
So, you know, the more, if you use the,
if you use the always
definition, which is the more,
the most exhausted, actually it's gonna,
it's gonna look even stronger, right.
So, I mean, I think that,
that the significance will
disappear maybe later on.
But if you use only the first patent,
you will still see a presence definitely
in the first decile and weaker afterwards,
but you still see the
patent very strongly.
Okay, I'm just going to skip this.
This is just what I said.
I mean, this is robust,
still using different GMI definitions,
using even stricter fixed effects,
different levels of aggregation.
We can aggregate everything
at the battle level.
You know, it's pretty, it's
pretty robust, remarkable.
- [AJ] Dany, this is AJ again,
can I ask you a question?
- Absolutely.
- [AJ] That was a fantastic
graph, I love this.
And just in terms of trying
to hypothesize a little bit
about why this might be happening,
do you think this might
be partly driven by like,
the country's specific policies
and in helping out with
immigration policies?
For instance, let's say quantum physics,
maybe a area of interest right now
for the American government.
So they make it easy for
the inventor to move.
It is stage,
let's say like when quantum technologies
in the more nascent stage, it's a...
I'm just giving you like a tiny example.
What do you think might be driving this?
This is such an interesting result.
- So what I'm going to try to, I mean,
with this method,
and I will welcome many ideas
because I'm leaning to it a little bit
on the controls I can put,
but so then now we're moving,
I'm going to move to some more tables
that I think is getting into that.
The very boring answer
to your question from me,
which is not, is not a
hundred percent yet, is that,
you know, we do use here
country year fixed effects,
technology year fixed effects.
You're talking about a
country-technology year fixed effect,
kind of thing.
- [AJ] Exactly.
- We do it, put here
country-technology fixed effect,
and it still holds.
It kills a lot of the variation,
but it's still holds.
It certainly can be, you know,
certainly what you're saying.
It certainly can be an issue.
And, and yeah, so, so
that's why, you know,
if we can tackle it with a
little bit better identification,
it will solve that.
But it's a great point.
And we, I don't think we
can go that far into that,
to claim that that's unexplained by that.
But you're absolutely right.
- Dany one more question.
So would this graph look
similar if you were looking
at GMIs who, like,
according to this technique
of using names are
immigrants, like thinking
that maybe diffusion happens
faster if you're returning
to your home country versus if you're not?
- So we, Ernest, I'm
going to call on you too.
We did, we did a lot
of this at some point,
and I think we didn't
really find big differences
between the two, but I might be,
I dunno Ernest if you want to jump in
or do you want to put it in the chat,
but if you think I'm wrong, but I,
we didn't find significantly
difference between the two.
I mean, we do find that
the effective returnees,
I'm going to find a little bit stronger.
But in terms of the diffusion,
if that's what you're referring to,
I don't think we found like
significantly different effects.
But, you know, we're still, we can,
I should, we should definitely
check that out again.
I'm calling Ernest all the
time, in the office in Europe.
So,
we've, and he says we did not
find differences in the graph
between immigrants and
refugees, and returnees, sorry.
All right.
So,
I mean, this is not exactly gonna get
to your point AJ, but I think,
again, it's a step on that direction.
So I think that the way we try
to really tackle this
relationship we're seeing
in the graph in a more rigorous way is
by changing a little bit,
the way we're estimating this.
And basically we're going to start,
I'm going to show you a lot of
tables with this regression,
estimating this equation
here in the middle
and this equation, basically...
So let me change the terms.
I know we're not supposed
to do that in theory.
So forgive me, but we
are like, we're trying,
but basically what we're doing
here is to actually look,
now our dependent variable
becomes patents that are
in the first decile.
So which you know, I
don't mean if these patent
that we're looking at is in the,
among the first ones
that we're looking at,
in that technology and country.
And to the right, we have also a GMI.
I should have said,
and I forgot about this.
This is really important that
the GMI, did I sand here?
Yes.
Do you see here?
How there's something that
says here previous experience.
So it's not, we're not only
measuring you're a GMI,
we're also measuring and
we're also assigning a one,
not only if you're a GMI,
but also you patented
in that same technology
before you came.
Okay.
So we're a little bit more strict.
It's not about, only
about whether you moved,
but whether you move and you
already have experience working
in that same technology.
Okay.
So, so that's a kind of an
additional level of detail
that we're going here when
we're doing this relationships.
And I'm sorry, I didn't
mentioned that before.
So we have, you know,
patents on the first decile.
Then we have, you know, our
main variable of interest,
whether you are a GMI
with previous experience,
we have some controls
at the inventor level
and at the patent level.
And then we have a bunch of fixed effects.
I mean, here, I think in the baseline,
we only have country year and
technology year, you know,
in the robustness, we have a bunch
with technology, country
and I have to see, AJ,
based on your question,
we can go as deep as
technology-country year.
I don't know if we have
enough power for that.
We also add here in the baseline,
a fixed effect for assignees.
So like, you know, if your patent for IBM,
we're going to have a
fixed effect for IBM.
Just because you might say, well,
maybe the person who's
moving within the firm,
or maybe they know how,
belongs to the firm somehow,
and the inventor is just executing, right.
So that way we're trying
to, getting rid of that.
And actually by the way,
this should be assignee
year fixed effect, okay.
So it's even more strict.
And the controls, which
I'm not going to show you,
but they have a bunch of
things such as the number
of non-patent literature,
the number of claims,
the size of the team,
the foreign priority,
whether there's a size of lag
between the filing date
and the granting day,
a bunch of things.
Okay.
Okay, so this is what we find.
So first the very simple
regression where we find that, yes,
being on the, you know, the likelihood of,
the likelihood of being,
of a patent being,
having a GMI explains which
much higher likelihood
that your patent is among the first ones,
is in the first decile.
This is what this
estimator is seeing here.
I'm trying to, to understand
better the economic.
I have to admit I was
running this last night,
these regressions.
So I'm still not there yet
with economic significance,
with economic interpretation,
because it seems to me a
little bit small economically,
to be honest, because if the likelihood
of being in the first decile
is by definition, 10%,
this increasing that, this
by 0.2%, by doing 0.2%,
that point, so it's not huge,
but I'm still working on this.
So I'm not going to get into that.
But we do find that as compared
to the other nine deciles,
and remember, this is,
this is a bit of a stricter test
because we're comparing the first decile
with the other nine, right.
So as compared to the, lay this 90%,
there's a much higher
likelihood that if you,
that if you're a GMI,
you're patenting in the
very first decile, okay.
And here we're controlling
whether the patent is a GCP,
a Global Collaborative Patents
and all the fixed effects
I told you before.
Here, we're kind of putting
in the same regression,
and this refers to what
I was saying before.
Like, if you are a GMI with
the previous experience,
but also if you're a GMI without
experience, so you really,
you just moved countries,
but you don't have,
you never worked on this patent before
and, you know, when we put
the two of them together,
the explanatory power
remains on those people
that actually have the
experience on that same patent,
which we think is a nice
quasi placebo test here.
Then we are kind of dividing
whether you are moving
within the same firm or
moving across firms, right.
And here, we really don't find,
there's no big difference.
But Diana a little bit to your question.
Not exactly, but here we do find
that when it comes to a returnee,
it's almost twice the magnitude
than when it's just an immigrant.
And I don't know if this is
a special power of returnees
or is it that most returnees are going
to developing countries
where there are some more,
I don't know, there's
more room for convergence
and, you know, more
technologies can be, can emerge.
So that's kind of our
interpretation, okay.
So this is kind of our main results.
You know, we're doing a little, again,
a lot of robustness stricter
fixed effect, segregation,
aggregation, coefficients
seem to be very stable.
We still find that, that coefficient seems
to be very strong and robust.
So,
what is this?
Okay.
So playing, I was
playing, I have to admit,
I was playing around yesterday to try
to show you a little
bit more heterogeneity.
It's not a very exciting table,
but I show it to you anyway.
So basically what happens, you know,
for different sub samples,
if we look at this relationship
with the same specification.
So, you know,
the first role is what
I just show you with,
you know, this has, by the way,
I don't know if you notice
is 15 million observations
because we are doing this
at the inventor level.
So this is the same
estimator we saw before,
when we, for instance,
divide between whether the
host countries are developing
or non OECD countries.
As OECD, you know, we do see a much,
there's many, many less
observations in non OECD countries
because most of the
innovation is happening
in the rich nations.
But nevertheless, we still find a much,
a bigger point estimate
by 50% in non OECD countries,
which I think is consistent
with this idea of returnees.
Most of them perhaps going
to the developing countries
when there's more room for,
for innovation and for new technologies.
We cannot divide these by periods.
We didn't find anything there,
but I'm not very surprised
because these are very short periods
to really study the phenomenon.
People might, you know,
we might lose a lot of
variation of people moving
between 09 and 2010, right.
So there's really,
I don't think it makes a lot of sense
to divide this in periods.
And when we do these types
of technologies, you know,
we do find, I don't think
that is terribly interesting,
but, you know, patents in electricity,
they seem to be there.
The 89 observations of
General Tagging seems to,
seems to have a very, very precise zero.
And patent of human necessities,
which I wrote down what that means.
Human necessities are...
Where is it?
Agriculture, food, health,
clothes, personal items.
So I think most of the things
that we use in our day to day,
these things seems to, you know,
explain our fixed diffusion of know-how.
So, you know, we're trying
to figure out a better way
to release heterogeneity analysis,
but this is kind of a
direction we're there.
And actually it seems, I'm going to finish
before the end of my time,
because I just have one more result.
Which is on the quality
of innovation, right.
So I think an important question
that remains is, you know,
I kind of show you the stylized
facts that GMIs patent,
much higher quality
innovations and quality,
you know, meaning innovations
that there are much
more cited, innovations,
like patents that are more cited,
patents that are more originally,
we have a bunch of measures
I'll show them to you.
To me, at least or to us,
I think most importantly,
the question is like,
if the knowledge is being
imported, to what extent,
you know, that's reflected
in quality, right?
So kind of like does early
presence of an experienced GMI
in a country-technology
life cycle translates
into a higher quality
patent in the future.
Like, is there a path
dependence kind of thing.
Like a GMI premium
on quality for the rest
of the life cycle of the innovation.
And to do this, we rely on this,
I mentioned it very briefly
on some quality measures
at the patent level
that was put forward
by a team in the OECD.
And we're using like these
measures, like forward citations,
which is the typical,
the most common measure for innovation,
something called breakthrough,
generality, originality,
radicalness, and an index that
takes all of them together.
You know, I can go through all of them
if you have a question,
but I have them all defined.
But these are the general,
just different measures
of quality of a patent,
how important they are,
how innovative they are
in their technologies,
how much do they rely
on other technologies,
how much do they open the
door for other technologies,
all these kind of things.
And basically the question
we're trying to answer,
the best way we found in trying to answer
and here's also some,
maybe there's a better way
and I'd love to hear about
that, is basically what is,
essentially, what is the
average quality per decile,
if in the first decile, there
was a higher presence of GMIs.
Okay, so it's basically kind
of interacting each decile
with the share of GMIs
in the first decile.
And I'm just gonna at the moment,
I'm not gonna show you a table,
I'm gonna show you a graph.
And the answer is that
we don't find anything.
I think, you know,
you would start to be suspicious
if I show you a half
results for everything.
So I'm showing something
I don't have results for.
So here, basically, you know,
this is the average quality in
each decile in the left graph
and this the GMI, you know,
if there was a GMI in
the first few patents,
what is the average quality,
what the GMI premium.
And even though the coefficients
are higher, you know,
they're not precise enough
to be able to say something.
So there's really no
difference in quality.
This is just with one measure of quality,
which is this index that has
all of them, but, you know,
it doesn't matter which
quality measure we use.
We don't really see a lot of differences.
So, you know, that's, you know,
we can't conclude anything very special
about GMIs playing a big
role in the initial stages
and also playing a big role in the quality
of the innovation in the future.
We just don't see any difference.
Needless to say, you know,
this is also done with
all the fixed effects
and all the controls,
et cetera, et cetera.
So let me actually start to wrap up, but,
and then maybe we can have
some time for questions.
I would love to hear your suggestions
because we need a lot of them.
So basically, what we're
trying to do here is
to contribute by continuing
to uncover a phenomenon of,
of growing importance in the
globalization of knowledge,
of the production of knowledge,
which is this Global Mobile Inventors
that we believe is an
under-researched phenomenon.
And we find that they have a crit...,
they play a critical role,
both immigrants and returnees
in the diffusion of knowledge
as we measure it, which
is through the emergence
of new technologies.
But they don't seem to define some sort
of quality path dependence.
And in terms of next
steps, you know, we do see,
we know that we have
challenges with identification,
some of you, you're raised here and,
and I totally agree.
So we did try some ideas, try to,
to kind of instrument perhaps,
where their movements and so on.
They were embursed, terribly successful.
You know, we are looking
off into other methods,
maybe looking something
into an order a probit
not to be so hard between
comparing the first decile
to the other 90%, and beyond
more precise than that.
And some things that we're
looking in the future,
some of them, we started looking already
to think about recombination
of technologies,
whether immigrant, whether
GMIs are playing a role
in countries combining technologies,
not just by looking at
the first, you know,
the main technology code of the patent,
but all the different technology codes
that a patent could have.
Looking into whether, you know,
this diffusion process
changes, whether you're,
the first few patents
are mixed teams or not.
I mean, is a GMI working
on his or her own,
or is the GMI working
with local inventors?
Does that play a role in the diffusion?
We certainly need to
play more a little bit
with heterogeneity and the sizes of firms
and also some more inventor heterogeneity,
internal demographics.
So, anyway, I'm going to stop here.
I thank you very much.
I know, again, this is, I mean,
I don't want to say it's
purely descriptive paper,
but I know that we have some
challenges in identification,
but I, we still think we're
adding a little value just
by really describing this phenomenon
and getting us the best we can,
but I will welcome more of your,
so far, excellent comments.
And thank you for being here.
Thanks for listening.
- Dany, quick question.
Very interesting by the way.
- [Dany] Thank you.
- I remember seeing at the best in paper,
some impact on the immigrants on citations
and the maximum value patents
and top patents, and I,
I was a little bit puzzled
when you show the no impact
on the patent outcomes.
And I was thinking if maybe
something on selection,
maybe of the migrants versus the GMIs,
or I don't know,
I wanted to get your ideas
on what you think could be
explaining the difference.
- No impact on the quality
measures. You mean?
- Yeah on citations, on the
forward citations or on, yeah.
- I mean, we do see the GMIs on their,
you know, on their own,
they, their patents are
of much higher quality
that we see,
we're trying here to get
to something that it's,
I don't know if it's a stretch,
but it was like, you know,
are they setting off, like
higher quality for the rest
of the people who are patenting
that country in technology,
and that's where we don't
find anything, right.
So like, if you remember the
example I gave at the beginning
of this Chilean scientists, Ismael Mena,
who came and did one patent, and then I,
I said that there were 19 other patents
that happened after him.
You know, we don't find that
these 19 other patents were
of much higher quality
than they would have been if you believe,
you know, being able to exactly
do during identification.
If they would have been
either, if Israel Mena,
Ismael Mena wouldn't have been there.
That's what we're getting at too.
So it's not inconsistent with the fact
that immigrants patent
higher-quality or GMIs.
We're trying to get a
little bit beyond that
and seeing if there's a
path dependence of quality
for the rest of their life cycle.
- Yeah, from the diffusion
component, and I was.
Yeah, I was just thinking
that the immigrants that will come
in permanently are more likely
to have that effect, right.
As opposed to the ones that
are maybe returning, but.
- Right, so here we're
pulling everybody together,
not only for patents by immigrants,
but patents for everybody.
So we could do that,
we could try to define,
you know, we, yeah, we
could look into that.
Thank you.
Yes, AJ.
- [AJ] Hi, I'm very
vocal today, but sorry.
So one question I had was that,
so what you're trying to
explain is that this existence
of the GMI, influence
the quality of patents
in the subsequent periods.
Another way of looking at the question,
maybe in which you may
have already looked at it,
whether is that maybe the same quality
of patent was going to arrive,
but maybe the time it took to get there,
maybe shortened?
Did I clarify myself?
So it's a question of not of
whether it was gonna emerge,
the same quality would
have emerged or not,
it's that it would have, would,
would it have merged in the same pace
in the absence of a GMI?
- Yeah, no, that's possible,
yes, that we're seeing.
I mean, yeah, it's
possible that the quality,
you're talking about the
quality in particular, right?
- [AJ] Quality in particular.
So the question would have
been if the same quality
of patent was going to emerge,
regardless of the existence of a GMI,
would it have still, would
it have emerged faster?
Cause I think,
the question you're asking is
actually a stronger question.
It's a harder thing to happen.
There must be in the way,
I'm not very familiar
with this literature,
but it's almost assuming
that there is something,
something inherently
different about the GMI
that would have, that would be linked
to the emergence of the
idea, which may be the case,
I don't know.
But to me, it sounds like the question
that's asking me differently
about the timing is a
slightly more lenient way
that could help you
generate further ideas.
- Okay, I might follow up
offline with you on that
because I want to make sure I got it,
but I think that's a great
point, if that's okay with you.
Thank you.
- [AJ] Of course.
I think Lucien has a question.
- [Lucien] Oh yes. Thank you.
Great presentation.
So I don't know if I missed something,
but are you able to observe
the gender of the inventor?
I don't know, it would
be interesting to look
at how the point estimate,
come may change based on
the sex of the inventor.
So I dunno.
- Yeah, well, that's
kind of what I meant here
at the very last slide.
So like, but I went very fast.
So you didn't miss it,
you know, we might want to
look more into demographics,
so I don't think we have,
we don't have the gender,
but maybe their algorithms
and their names,
we can do something
to infer gender.
- [Lucien] Okay
- And we definitely would,
that's something that I'm
definitely interested in.
- [Lucien] Okay, thank you.
- I think Jeremy has a question.
- [Jeremy] Yeah, thanks.
I think this topic is really interesting.
I'm wondering if, you know,
as you work on this more,
you can say more pushed forward
on what drives the emergence
of GMIs in the first place.
So I'm wondering, you know, are GMIs,
like, this is related to
heterogeneity by, you know,
like, characteristics of
the country of origin,
but are GMIs more likely
to come from countries
that are more, say advanced
in the industry where they
are then patenting in?
And if so, why are they
migrating to patent?
I think these sorts of
questions are interesting.
I'm wondering if you have
any thoughts about that?
- Yeah. I mean, that's super interesting.
We have some thoughts,
but more like from the
identification part, right.
Like trying to see if there's something
that could explain these
movements, you know,
in ways that it's not
related to anything else so
that we can explore a little bit of that,
but I don't think we have,
I mean, I think, it's a good question.
I think everything,
there's a lot of information
we could do to get there.
It's all gonna be very endogenous right,
as we have it,
but it's certainly a good
direction to go for, into now.
Thank you.
- [Jeremy] Yeah. Thanks.
- Yeah.
I dunno if there's any
more questions I want
to be respectful of everybody's time.
- [Sanjeev] So like,
I will again come back
to my earlier question
like do have some sense
about like, you know,
what are the push or pull
factors when it comes to GMIs?
Like, are they being attracted
or are they being pushed
out maybe financial crisis
or recession during periods
in Latin-American countries
and all are playing a big
role in pushing people out
of the country?
Like, do you have some
intuition about that?
- Yeah, I mean, I just, and,
this is kind of the universe
of inventors, right.
So, so some extent.
There's certainly, there has to be some,
we haven't explored this very much,
so there has to be some cases
in which we can explore
some push and pull factors,
it's probably not going to
apply to the whole sample.
And that's something we
could certainly look at
to see if there is.
I think the main challenge there is
that because most of the
inventors are actually located
in a few rich countries,
which, you know,
there's not going to be a lot
of variation of like political.
I mean, who knows, I mean,
after what happened the
past four years, who knows,
but there's not going to be
a lot of variation, I guess,
on, if you're thinking
about identification,
which is what I'm thinking,
because most of them are either going
or coming from the rich countries.
- [Sanjeev] Yeah, so that,
I was thinking maybe
like segmenting your data
along similar countries,
like, in a movement amongst
similar countries versus like,
you know, countries which
are very dissimilar,
so on economic criterion, like, you know,
maybe movement from OECD
countries to America versus
to countries like India,
which is quite poor.
And how does that impact
the quality of patents.
It will very nice to...
- Yeah, we can look into, I mean,
the closest to that is kind of
that table I'd show you very
fast where we're seeing like,
the fact I'm not, when,
when we will only look
at non OECD countries,
there was like, the
magnitudes were higher,
but you know, yeah.
There's so much we can do with this.
That's a great recommendation, I agree.
I mean, these are all
super great comments.
I so much appreciate all of them, really.
- [Sanjeev] Thank you.
It's very interesting work.
Thank you
- Thank you.
Next time, I'm coming in person.
(Dany and Sanjeev laugh)
- [Teresa] Thank you very much.
And I think for other questions,
so if we can contact Danny,
we can circulate the email,
and so for everyone.
Thank you very much Dany, for everything
- [Dany] I don't mind,
bye everyone, thank you.
- [Teresa] Bye.